mein ist is now a really
fantastic podcast with controversial
views surprising forecasts from
someone who really knows he's talking about
because he has the style and the feeling for the
separate the future in his blood we're
talking about renato ok if one
of the most successful german rappers right now
at all from bietigheim
bissingen on eur places let's go with
renato welcome inside or
renato good morning i'm in
bietigheim if he's
actually i'm
in bietigheim yes so that's what it
looked like for you the story that you
grew up in a small village  you're somehow
in bietigheim bissingen and meanwhile
the colts fattening with somehow tim cook
from apple yes that's kind of a fanny
narrative but well i stand
for this small town folk do yes
let me say or this
that the forgotten part of
germany but yes i am
I actually read my bio properly, I
've been on the road a lot  n as a
child i am a gastro child and i have moved 25
times
seldom does a restaurant have yes i am such a
classic guest worker gastro child so
i am 100 percent
my mum came during the war my father came
here as one of the last guest workers
and then you can also look at each other
that these restaurants and hate having to
we posted them
didn't work that well either so i
don't know what your parents the browser
would have had a lot of success yes
that's a topic in itself i think that
's how i pronounce many foreigners
like that  the soul when you then and i
think it's not a german phenomenon
i think it's a worldwide one
speaks for many migrants somehow
the first the first chance you
usually have for the generation that
really comes up until now then the second
generation grows up and then
Education has opportunities for social
advancement, but the first chance that
the migrants themselves have is
mostly  somehow culinary what then
somehow hipsters always think is really
cool if they can eat it
but for the people who do
it that's usually the only thing
they can do and
unfortunately there are also a lot of
information gaps that means it's
usually very true  a lot of work a lot of
diligence also with very little
entrepreneurial ability and that
usually leads to these
tales of woe i mean confess
then somehow the kebab shop the donner
kebab shops in the area somehow undercut each other in terms
of price and the
only
entrepreneurial idea they all have is
okay we have to  beat another price
or we have to
somehow offer him 800 grams of meat for three euros,
that means you look at the world
in a very entrepreneurial way,
i mean right now for the artist
it
will be okay i can now that i mean
you have  Yes, I graduated and
then also a few
semesters in a classic way  I think printing technology is
studying printing and media technology,
yes, that was the
student alibi that somehow my mother
could sleep too, so we're back to
the subject of the second generation, which of
course then tries
to climb the social ladder through education, that's something like that for
the parents  a
hammering studying without love otherwise you will become a
garbage man here it is always earlier today
you know you want it is not even such a
bad job
that yes well that just happened through
life well well that came at some point
and above all because of elvir so a lot a
lot  entrepreneurial knowledge so
i actually have almost everything through lwl
as the eleventh that you can say about it is a
mutual friend of all of us his
producer partner for me an old
pleasure podcast was
with us again and again soon
a podcast conspirator was to come
years ago  namely also just
met the gallerist japan eat just so
more like an old  he friend of the house
omerbegovic in whom the best regards who
also say yes to you as my mentor
in the things definitely but
you were already with
other labels as an artist
so i was briefly part of a
collective live from proved
but that was because i had my only
story so to speak before about my
own solo starter and you made
music but ok logically because
i got into
that then i don’t know a professional
career you can actually say that
started with lw or with the
founding  then from the vision so where is
it really about it then that was
just my profile that thing and i
then started to entertain 100 percent of my
life how to
earn with it but when you start the
passion that's a long time ago it
started  then at some point with don't know that
you can do that you can do that at 14 13 14 or something like that
but let's say about texts yes that's
how it is then and then you start e.g  u
write and then at some point mike
and then so that's a really long time ago and
vivica marcel like so when i know
that he's going around and looking
can be found that brought out other big
names so now because that's
not true
i was that was easy
yes you can see
that in a variety of ways that religiously i would say, for example, but that one would say that it was
a happy coincidence
from a
religious point of view one would now say
that it was the universe or that the quantum
falls there are also different
perspectives on it or fate
but that that  So it was the right
moment, so I was somehow
almost on the verge of even stopping
with the music and how did it happen then you saw
what was posted was probably that it was
that the contact came through
so lw had basically I hope I
'm not telling [ __ ] but  who
had been planning
to start a new project with them for a long time, which was
then almost between d  he new music
lives
with a fresh breeze with new
perspectives with new approaches
so everything is new and they
had been looking for him for a long time
no garden for it and
then michael weiner wrote to me i
was still kind of a genius in the
industry back then so it  As you already
noticed, there were already a few
things from me, but
because I stayed here back then and didn't go
into the industry in any way and didn't
look for these parties and stuff like that, nobody knew
where I was or nobody had either
contact possibilities apart from people with
whom i really worked
and then the man michael
caught me on facebook he
found me and wrote to me and yes the rest
is a bit of history
it's kind of a coincidence in the end it's
from bietigheim because  that's the way it is
for you too but active so
many other musicians now can give
me a pau
se it's not a coincidence but I think
we'll find out that
nobody had anything to do so I did
it separately from each other all by chance in the
same place exactly so we have of
course each of us has
overlaps so browser for example
is a child as a friend  from me
for more than ten years we also did
temporary work together here in the
new factory he is longer
has so i also had the packaged
machine he was on the good i was a
calendar 1 is supposed to be the fastest machine
with the here none  I have no idea how many degrees steamrollers
and yes, ladies, the intersections and
I also had my intersections with
are never we have also worked together a few
times and so we
have all
crossed our paths sometimes longer sometimes shorter but
in the end each of us has his
career completely  started and established independently of the other
and that
's crazy when you
think about it and how it works today  his
career started so he always got to know the same thing he
knows how to do
something he's actually in the producer
life more today so it's
been six years now so
it's different again that's the
case like that it's been six years
today I have no idea six
decades so it was back then
so what happened at some point by
chance like a one song yes or yes
so that I had exactly we put out a
bit of music in this context of
life I have a little ep there
back then i don't even know
how strong it was i think it was eight
songs or so
and then we had a little bit of a
scene heikki was the real
favorite back then so it was mainly for
julian so he got it from his
partner and that was him too
the reason for coming together it was the
initial spark it was the friendship
between me and him that's
why i dreamed of that moment
and that  then it was like that then
at some point it was ok how could it
go on i noticed
this music sound like it could be something
and i then thought it was okay
what was a logical
decision back then but not so logical at all
i was faced with the  decision was so
okay we kind of have a hype but
i was like that
am i successful now because i am part of
this hype or am i
successful because i do what he
does well and i asked myself this question and then i had
almost
no idea what  The future bids me
farewell to this moment and I
said I couldn't live with
not knowing whether it was my fault or whether I
was just lucky
somehow soon encountered the right crew at the right time and what
we said earlier where  was it like that
then maybe I'll just leave it
with the ok maybe I'll go
back to the university for a bit
and have a look  with something that
happened on the side and then you can get this
message from michael and then
i met elvir and that was
then management help really otherwise
truth within two seconds
really two seconds i had to so
we both knew so okay we have
exactly the same vision  exactly the
same wishes exactly the same
problems with what's going on and
in the music industry it's
because he was already so successful
, most of them had an idea that
elvira would have lured me with a suitcase
full of money, which wasn't the case at all
but he lured me with
erda believed me and he
we had the same vision that was the most
important thing at the time and that
was the reason why
it worked how do you have it
now that is then that is
that me  I think that could be so I
can tell you from an artistic point of view
and I can explain it to you
with the met  riken as i
understood you but i think
that would be more interesting if you the l4
freaks if you him coming if it means what
do you mean you somehow just
leased music or or or released
songs and there have
not been more and more like with spotify  listeners
accumulated so if you're really stupid seen
from the outside and you've
done a lot live than I mean live
there they're something because especially
thousands of dynamics that played with
it partly controlled and partly
not controlled but
nowadays after six years you know
too  or do i know in the meantime a
lot of it is not in your hands at all
although you think so i think that
is that's also a problem for many
artists
when you have to learn that in
this area of art in particular a lot of things are not as ag
nt of one hand as you are  So you think of
course it means the music business and
that summed it up quite well, especially in the interview
, as 50 proze  nt
music and 50% business and that that's
just the way it is, you have to make it
clear if you somehow intend to
be at the start for a long time, but that means
you have to stick to the
basic business
rules,
which is really difficult again
So is the top 2 3 rule
finances under control top 1
definitely you just don't
have to have it under control top 2
structure making art yourself needs
structure so of course you ca
n't grasp art you can too
there's no guarantee it's not it's
not  athletically measurable so of course
there are now metrics in the world where
you can now measure whether it should be
successful or not but
you still can't measure there are
songs that haven't reached a large
mass but a single person
mean the world that's what it's called art  not as
blatantly measurable as it would be, for example, sport
or something like that, but you definitely need structure,
so you can with structure
there is no guarantee  ntie but you can
increase the probability that you
can drive these moments as you
want them commercially with a higher
probability
and there are from 3
no I think those were the two but
there are a few let's say
mechanics that I thought of  that they are
actually important we today's
music business for example
musicians of his generation because with
genre big social media have to be
relevant because i learned at bones
tram the super crass
insta game really big coverage
then i took a look and
realized you do it  relatively little
you have how also that will be a success
small hardly not whether the consequences for 1000
people that of course a lot but now that
someone of the 700 but yes ok but still
that is still how little so how
you have the hall in your country is
easy  little and you don't have the choice
somehow 30 post or something like
that because that's why I have that again and again
not that much well
so what you mean is first of all
social media is just a
tool like the newspaper used to be
somehow or television or something like
that media is just an umbrella term
so without that alex change
and  now it's just social media but
just like it is in entrepreneurship you
can of course build a company is trade
on social video
but what i find is a shaky topic is
because somehow building
a whole construct
on zeitgeisty dynamics
in the current media landscape is
somehow a bit too  wobbly so
that can be a great tool to bring something
up somehow or
to create visibility but
basically as you can see well i
have no idea if i
fold the curtain down
here because somehow almost 30 gold
records
we have no idea i have  every
live festival headliner in germany
what is there i have every hall
ausver  buys in germany that exist
and i don't even have a million
followers on instagram but that's
where they almost like you think but is
n't the business not wrong
so we don't have to say it's not really inviting so not
exactly he find these days  i do
n't even matter that much anymore because
social media has only become such a huge
advertising space i think the
trend will also completely
reverse itself so if you look at the
trends in recent years, especially in
hip hop, i.e. in germany it's
not like that yet  arrived but in the us reporters
hardly any artists who are the
culturally most important and
most successful artists are hardly on
social media
tyler the creator
also has terrible so if you
compare it with an account from drake
or something like that you will come up with exactly the same
things that is  a super small
account playboy cover from the rolling stone was
declared the most important album of the year
has no p  ost social media
and posts four times or so a year
so that's ne that's pretty
old-fashioned from the point of view so I think
also in terms of costs so I should have
thought about it that was exactly that the big successes
come with the big reach he is at
cordes  the problem you are confusing
you are
confusing success with visibility and
that the problem is what many are doing
these days, so many many too,
be it companies, be it in the
entertainment sector or in another
area, everyone is a bit
paralyzed by usability and everyone is the
way it is  the same success and
that's usually not the case because
you can't
simply convert cultural importance into visual that
's not true that's
never been so definite even in the age of
social media there were somehow artists
who didn't exist every day  you would want
that now if you
would go back now indycar 60s,
so to speak, that of the artist i  n the one who has
the most scandal is the
most successful won't say it either
, but even today one tries to convert it
in the same way
and to say that the master has the
visibility is the most successful
and I think that will be
crass for many again  will fly in the
face with this thinking because
i'm coming instagram now
as a platform is dead at least the
younger generation so if you're
somehow under 18 you wo
n't be able to tear anything on instagram anymore
there are hardly any
creators who  then arise again or
so that then everything is too crass right now
everything tik tok and on tik tok
going around much more organic hre things
so of course there is just tik tok to
this content inflation also drive
faster and
faster and faster and faster more and more and less and less
money  also earn for content in the
first place I say was much more must
just about the management  t is coming but
I think many many will fly in the
face join in yes I
do yes I was there very
early on and you were there you were there
I think I have one of the strongest
German rap accounts and was close to the
200,000 die  I don't post much there I post
like on instagram as I feel like it
but it's so we'd
say I'm more at home now
wdr w so yes, above all, so it's
just so
I find this idea the many  have eg they
say so most have yes if
they have a lot of posts we have a purpose
behind it we want sibylle ti and
i think a lot more
liberated today and says why should i
waste time for months on account
maintenance
when these companies accept me with a kiss
and I can just pay
for this shitty reach for the one post
I want,
so why should I waste half a year of my
account and the time I
spend on et  something else could invest,
for example in product maintenance, so
i can make my niche product better,
make the presentation better
and if i feel like it, for example
, and say i want
to go to the next promo video for
no idea for my next music
snippet or something  if i want showers to have
range then i can have them for
little money in the end or i
can say okay i have to do
40 stories every six months now
that's just playout i think
one of the big questions in german
digital business is what could a
german  super app and maybe it
could be something like that, at least for
me it's that I'm really extremely
often off in the morning because you
can rent cars there for a few minutes but
also for longer you can rent scooters here
is a good variety of providers above
all  things is pretty simple so
from
metals like in it that's why for him power
i have as an app crazy  it makes a lot of sense
if you want to be flexible, so to speak, be
mobile with a wide variety of
services everything is possible just
download it and have a look probably to be
fair not in all cities spring is as
perfect as in hamburg the
coverage and the range of services were
much larger than  in other
cities, but meanwhile
there is a comprehensive range of mobility options in all
cities in germany or most of the larger ones,
that's why it was discovered early everywhere
,
but isn't it still so that
for many it was a great liberation to be able to communicate
directly with fans with people who
like you
to have direct channels that's always been
said that the big advantage and
that sounds yes and yes, that's
so, this supposed
democratization at the beginning was
great, but that
actually backfired in all sectors, so
let it be in streaming  be it that youtube
be is everything so with everything he is
now it
actually backfired for everyone,
so we enslaved ourselves a bit to the algorithm
and
I
just don't go down this path, so it's not
important either, in the end culturally
good things are done and there are 1000
really quite a few  examples in every
industry a good product it will
always prevail that in the end how is that
now more percent do you think that
spotify will install it just as much as over over
then it’s dead
dead not but i think so spotify
okay it’s the market leader in germany but
i think  all streaming platforms
while also having a problem do you
really mean 100 percent but where do you get it for
sure well look here art will always
exist art you can't
kill it art will always
develop art will always be there
when we both  are no longer in this
world, art will exist,
art will be created that means d  this
platform will often come up against
their stumbling blocks so
what the platform is now all having as a
problem they have they have problems with
the decline of hip hop
and rap hip hop has a problem with the
decline of social media
is gone so the decline of hip
hop  that's exactly the problem so all
these streaming providers
recognized it sometime in 2016/17 okay we
want what do they all want to be
big otherwise yes they want sales they
want ergo user time on the app and
user numbers those are the two
most important metrics i would
let's just say they deserve it, so they recognized it
was crass cooper hip hop to the genre
what brought the most safe drive
and where did the 34 from social media
and from jude law wanted exactly be it
two people two huge dynamics
have merged so much  grabbed
social media hip hop needed what
constantly made content because it
constantly because all these artists huge
content t  caused raffic or
caused huge traffic so the
thing is now at one point it
's over that means
hip hop in general as a topic does
n't just
get great traffic on social media now there are
no longer individual artists of course there are
individual artists or they will become
artists  but so
these general giant gold
diggers hype the staff somehow cause a lot of traffic 2016
until corona there is no longer that
means it is again about the quality of
individual topics or the
interesting heath of individual topics
I think there is a music recreated
quasi years  well definitely not that
you can see but I think a lot of
either hip hop will
develop again or it will just be replaced
by something
so it's noticeable but it can well
so otherwise everything is so all
right well but that's already
over  so in all metrics you
can look at it up to 50 60 percent
in the total number  to say en burglary and mainz
which is also on instagram so
I mean that instagram has a
huge problem with tik tok that is
also not a must not be a fortune teller now
because until now no whistleblower age
about that not with so that was just
above having that now  now just
the people there
, some of them all somehow made sure that they were pushing
their thing there was hardly any
curation
there was hardly any cultural curation
all streaming providers have opted for
hip hop said okay the maine playlists were all hip hop
most of them  most active playlists are
hip hop like that and now that i'm not
cool anymore everyone just lacks the tools
for there is music outside of hip hop
like that and you have the problem is with
this streaming model you took
everyone else's breath away and  i
say that even though i have benefited from this hype
completely so i
have this golden age hip hop and golden
age streaming completely mi  t taken so
the normal season is over I mean
the positive yes well the yes well for
hip hop yes and I think even if
you talk now in ten years there will also be a
lot of swing and providers I think many
will no longer be profitable
simply so it will be for example  who when
i met him he
showed me a new song had so new
so singer songwriter same up to
cuddly songs almost
that may be
that as a singer/songwriter let's say
I had so on is not
what he told you  shown that was schmidt and
that is for example i think i will be a
significant artist of the new era
who also just so it's about again
i think it's about content again there
will be more content greven
just like tik tok so even if  it's
funny even if it's actually called
a bit
like the app for children
and that's not true
anymore, so pixar is also a lot
black  Easier to manipulate like
instagram so instagram he has a
clear model without things so for
example this topic
wealth and prosperity so stupid flexes
often viktor does
n't work as well as it is on instagram
so there are some figures from
because the series or  so the yes giant
careers are just stupid with such a
junk thing somehow with yes
thank God I knock on wood that
I'm doing great financially
so you know what shows that also so
yes not much but pleasant but that
does and you look there  on or
somehow a g class or something like that
yes you've already done the stuttgart cars
here and there i like driving
our swabian
engineering masterpieces
i think you have so i think
maybe that's [ __ ]
maybe [ __ ] i completely but
i think  in ten years it will
be another big
big democracy within the next ten years  there will be
content for the topic in general
so i think at some point i think it will be like this
at some point and i
'm not a huge tryptophan or
sona right now but i think at some point there will be
some possibility based on the blog chain
to just simply and
simply curate content
and upload it  to enter into a contract directly with the
user because in the end
you can already see that in many other
industries, so when
we talk now, for example, about the
fashion industry, I know the label
raises out son as first as a
consumer and then also as
distribution list yes or no
yes so I'm also with the
designer I hope I can stop that soon
and hand it over
there it goes in the same direction so of
course there are these online
mega retailers like susi canceling the
drivers try they will always
larger and the conglomerates are becoming more and more violent,
but on the other hand
it is also becoming more and more frequent  ger and always
co so people want this
curation and want these little
niche worlds and it's
really just about director
customer there isn't one so most bands
don't go to these super
retailers anymore and they don't want that at all
so they can no
longer maintain this margin, but they
say hey, I prefer to offer this, this better
margin directly to the customer, I
don’t have to add the triple cathode to
ten times the price, just so that
somehow something deserved is missing
from it, but I offer that
I have my own structure right here on my website
and I mean that's it,
that's all of them, then most of
them started out like that before they were
somehow bought up by the big
ones and some just stay with the
concept and some sell  but
you can't blame
them for that either, but I think that will also
affect music and stuff at some point, but
i  Isn't it still like that? You need
something like that in marketing
jargon, like the touch points, so
if you're doing something awesome, no one can see it,
then it won't help either,
so I mean you have to
somehow find a way for people
to pay attention to your things  makes
and now only now again such a tool and
then of course there is a large cooperation
with rider field also a troubadour is
sort of in their distribution channel somehow
and since we are
made visible by them how will it be possible
to do it alone without social media without big
partners so what does that mean here  without social
media
so social media can be used as a
tool but that doesn't mean that
you
somehow
have to be a slave to this attention economy that you somehow have to
perform like there are other ways
through good ones  content and such
and there are many examples of this, from fashion to
entertainment, the
r  eformen or there finding your mouthpiece
and not just flooding everything with
[ __ ] so there is
not only black and white there is this
golden mean and I think that will
I think that will be rather
interesting in the next few years I
think that will be the case  there is also more
attention for real, organic, cool content,
or there is also a look that
might fit in well with the fact that
over the last few years
everyone has been trying to constantly release new
songs or
somehow otherwise not always progressing
update almost to somehow
always benefit in the playlists
or just hack a little bit of this whole
spotify economy
you seem to be on record
so you somehow release records
and then sometimes not 12 13 songs
on it and then comes the next one then
come  new record again so i dealt with
it a bit almost antiquated
well good  album hasn't died out yet
i think it will
change that i'm also
aware but first of all of course i'm an alkomat first of all i
was a consumer
too so that's always the
thing but i think it's always
fanny  so why are we all here we are back
on the subject like sibylle who just because
something has somehow worked well for 34 years
everyone is always so
frozen they can no longer imagine any other
reality it is like
this and then you have all this
data driven duz
they just always freeze for something like that
because they can’t
look further than the number and I
can’t really recognize
and understand something like that because they
don’t make decisions from the heart
and so I know how many
you have to somehow see the media
or something where i know okay i know
that the company is not doing so well
but you are just n  really stupid and
since half fell for their social media lines
because seven and you just saw
them on the big instagram account or
if they invest there somehow big
companies or so much too much money where you
already know okay they are actually
already on the descending branch  or
this whole construct and the
whole wave is already on the
decline because people
have forgotten how to look at things culturally
music also has a very big problem
as you say who the majors i
mean it doesn't matter they are a
huge company  so there's just the
brand chase and
somehow who made how
many placements at the end of the year in
contrast to the other majors
so but also on a smaller level
there are hardly any
people who make artistic
decisions like that  only sat down on
social media and if that
will soon be over because
there are also many things dear tik
tok for example happen and now
you see the stream of people
who are somehow crazy brand there
is now for example this
gold rush mood every bird pictures
now somehow start his song galaxies and
funny trend or something and you
notice orcas that's all easy
99 percent of the time it doesn't work
and most of the things that somehow
cause such a large traffic are things
that were not
initiated by these artists at all are in the oldest
really in the very rarest
case it really was initiated by the
artist are mostly  trends
that they have no influence on and there
you see the problem then there are
some people who then somehow
tik tok stages and then they realize
that [ __ ] doesn’t replicate
that at all, which means they will all have
to come back very quickly and they
will  everyone has to go back to
artists where the legend says august he
can do something so he can do something  s apart
from the thing from social media he has he
has a toolbox and the thing is
i think but in this
generation these artists will never
design anymore because
we used to need the music industry we were you
didn’t have the structure you can
you the  technology there today everything is
democratized and affordable you
can produce world hits with 1000 euros
believe solos is still
possible to do like that the musician jan where you now have the same relevance for
the next two three
decades like today
100 percent so if you meet art
you will work that
doesn't mean that you won't have an incursion into your
attention, so if you
measure it in the metric then it
will spend cents in every career my
album won't go down so well
or a phase of yours won't
reach as many people
as another phase did, but
it shouldn't be measured in any case
, not as  artist
what do you think of the metrics on the show is
when i mean you are in this
business gmbh now but if you
somehow don't hear from anyone
or you don't try to understand anything what
someone is doing then you look what kind
of halls they are playing you look at  what
many plane spotters do you look at in so
-called nutritional and not so
full so it's just about
understanding art so either you have it
or not so either you can
read does this boy have something on it so
that they said stupidly that's why there is
so terribly little  people who
can do something like that or are good at assessing
it that's something you
either have or don't have your
heart for and you can understand
what's good and what's not or not
so you can't learn that
nobody can teach him that is  there are
just as many people in its corporate world
who simply understand this company will
lose what someone has seen that
that is not there  no number
that pointed to
it there was no no idea there were no user numbers
or anything that would have indicated it
but they just
understood it cool idea and i think it
would work and that's how it is
even if so it's mostly like that
in art  what metrics did
apple use to decide that you became
artist of the year, so to
speak, i think, based on those metrics,
i think because at least in
german rap i
made the most progressive album of
the last four five
years by a huge margin
and i think it has  gave me this honor
and then when
you reported it, people and we would
simply counter-award and the
award then also means that
you were with tim cook as Apple's ceo afterwards
, so I'll have the
internal ones then  basically
got the thing said hey we would
so you are our doctor is looking for yes and
d  ann there is production and stuff
for that and then sometime later
i got the message haye in
the course of that we have a little
surprise you have time next time too
tim cook would like to talk to her
so the old one here was
related to europe  and on germany
or on the world market then something on
germany ok and then you talked to the
thing about the bug like that
we made fun of mark zuckerberg a bit
she actually wanted to know i wanted i
wanted that way i know of course
ice cold professional  and of course he didn't
say where he could be prosecuted but
in his I
checked my sugar level I forgot
unfortunately I will but I still have the
recording
and he laughed heartily about it
which I noticed so no it wasn't a
professional like that  you noticed i
arrived right here but i
noticed okay there is tension in the
air and i have i have i  hm
actually thoughts for these privacy
topics that I find super important that Apple is
promoting, of course there are
also insiders
who know more about it than I do
and they say that even that
somehow has gaps and so on
and that's not perfect but I think
it is already well known
that people are talking about something like this
nowadays and now somehow
you somehow notice that you are not just
your data factory and that it is
also worth protecting you sometimes sound
like you know what we say
our digital skeptics are critics
so digitally pessimistic maybe a
few things yes you i also love
many many dynamics and i also think
social media is a great
place great things can happen i just find
it
funny that sometimes people who have
been on the road in such industries for a really long time are
just so
shocked  of numbers so if we
pay again away from the computer and just
go back somehow  t it also
kinda be subconscious or something
now not about wanna be
spiritual or something like that would sometimes
look like religious or something like that
but just go back to your
consciousness for a quick check and
I think
that's cool gives me what gives
gives me  what's in here gives
me some kind of artistic or
fulfillment that makes me happy or it
can also trigger negative emotions or
does it make me angry or scared
or something like that but it
triggers some real emotions
and I think you should go back
it's that  you have to
say goodbye to the digital market but
from the heart and from the soul you
have to listen to it a little bit again
i don't think it's bad it
was a completely different topic if i now take
a look at what you did
last time then you don't just have
clothes and  jobs from von yes in the
end they are pullovers on all things i
think soler t shirts are the basic product for a long
time  ukt is a classic suite
from exactly the cotton rudi about
now so that in the course of the year
our range will be expanded i would say
but still stay in the classic
streetwear framework and do you eventually do a
real shop or do you
only ever do jobs
we have said goodbye for a while
as of last year from the printing system
but if things are going up again
then you just have to enter an address
and the next blog me right now
but we were offline online for three and a half months
we have now just been
taken offline for a short two weeks
because probably about that
then stay online again for the whole year there will be
a real clothing label from
the yes yes i know so despite the
system we also found noise and also
said goodbye to it because
simply
sustainable is not itself not only
sustainable in the ecological sense but
i find it  also just not cool for the brand
i think that i  st
no that's it also stood up to
this so a lot a lot streetwear and hip
hop is also a topic that has
intertwined and streetwear
has also used a lot of hip hop promo
dynamics that means both have
mutually benefited from this giant shark
and  just as there was this
front according to marketing in hip hop
this always so huge lead
times just
stay on average snippets heppenheim and
best of all stop climax at the climax
comes the product the song or the
drop or something like that and ideally it's
somehow after  one week everything already
forgotten so i think this
model is in itself i think for
fashion for hiphop for everything is dead is
also dead so let's talk about it
calendar well yes because they are all still
just yes films are have no idea
but i have now  let's explain it like this it
's honest ran a lot they wo
n't talk about it anymore so really no
artist you won't become it  there is
n't a single
not a single top five hip hop song
this year that got up with this metric
none what is nico
for example does it still exist or yes
but it's just an old culture
and this old this old crowd of buyers
is just socialized with it and stays
of course still in this
pattern of behavior but will continue to get
involved you're no longer getting on this
model somehow but tell
me i explained it to myself that it
works because it's just the
countermovement on the internet the internet
makes everything always available to me twenty
four seven  can you go shopping
somehow everything is always there
and today you didn't feel like it anymore because
wanted something but precise but
neat it's just a
marketing tool most of the lies so 90
percent of the market just
uses it as a marketing tool which is what it is now
big conglomerates playing with
[ __ ] like that what they just [ __ ]
i  st there are only contingents
released and then it is
just ordered more precisely so
sometimes it is also
only possible with supporters and so quite so yes victories
about jesu valencia was for example a
good example this now tough one
just went to the order  four
times god has been doing that for ages so it
was the model only pre order which is
somehow still cool i think
for the consumer it's just
[ __ ] so i don't feel like
paying 800 euros for poly which will
only be available in four months  that means
in the end it's just a rip off
in most cases
and according to the drop principle this is also
just a rip off so most fire spots just do
their job offline after ten minutes but that's
what I mean most of these corporate birds
have no idea about it  although there are
a few there already no idea
if you believe that and then
these are that so e  in a great principle
that our agency is in the
schitt and when new brands
are somehow launched that's how
we go according to the principle and then
we want and what happened to a truth
that then as all these
zombie brands have somehow been
created  and then somehow
a small contingent is ordered then
it is somehow put offline after
ten minutes you see and then it
, strangely enough, after two
days the Riester is somehow
advertised hey people the Riester in
two weeks because that [ __ ] doesn't work
sold
how did you come to be
involved in your latest collab in protection exactly
food which is also a beverage company
i know who marko came from tripoli in a close
friend of elvir probably because
they connected so our guide is
first of all we basically want to
work with german companies although
not a single
not a single founder or shareholder
German p  as has for our
german origin is we
all still have such a regional
connection and or who for
our own region and i am
because i know the difference
i have more or less relatives who were born with me in
germany
i.e. all my cousins  everyone came with
me a hospital partly in the
same room as i was born and everyone
had to go back after the war and the
only difference is that my father was
n't a refugee but a
guest worker and that's why i had the residence permit so i
know
the real difference and i'm pretty
grateful to have grown up here that's
why i feel his
connection to germany even if
i still come across such small acceptance stumbling blocks again and again
, i've still learned not
to overrate them and just to be thankful because of
beck growing up here
to be allowed to be
therefore me  I'm just yes I'm already
German with a migration background
in this case it's in Germany
but also no language residents yes
I have well I don't have German
citizenship which I
should really care about I just find
a few at home yes but I
want them  I definitely
didn't have the time because it's
really that's a huge act that's a
huge oppermann that's really a
huge market
and yes just briefly trying to finish the
lively man that's
why we were all so close in
Germany  there is always such a
huge problem with such a
self-portrayal
, especially in this age tement and
art & fashion area, it is always the case
if something is good in Germany,
then it will immediately try to
hide the fact that it comes from Germany
, it is mostly cases like this or  it
will not carry forward that it is
a german brennt although we are
in so many areas
yes ma  are essential for the for the whole
world so let's now clearly go through a
junior and auto technology or something like that
we don't have to talk big now but even
in the subject of design we should definitely have
world-relevant topics specials on your
studies boss now in the new area
we have gmbh
the great performers who were also one of the
first German labels to
take place again in paris
gegenmodellen gmbh from berlin two guys
from berlin
and also with a migration background also
have a wonderful story to
tell that has really healed
and and and and the spots just
don’t have that  under the bushel that you are
German and that is also a
topic where I say there must be more of it
and that's why we try to
mostly only work with German
brands and then you know
then elvira and marco also know
a German brand  also in the raptor
in all other european she is
nice foot service however so has to up up
there were also market leaders for sale
as an independent company
that didn't exist anywhere else either
that everything belongs to the big
and no idea power and so on
and granini and blah and
that's kind of like that raptor was
in the
food industry  and that then
just fitted perfectly together
so now you can buy a loop
so according to your brand of drink in the
supermarket and what's in there
so what a miracle tastes it I think
a mango base
urgently not no because
I don't have a single one yet  got hold of
[music]
I got the bottles,
yes, but they are empty, I got
a lot of them, yes, not
to make a month and stuff like that,
but I haven't gotten one that's
full yet  man there exactly your
taste rather that you actually spent a
long time without digital screens it
was about the taste it was about the
message it was about  the trade fair was
about these two take companies
meeting each other it was mainly about being
it
have now found little
room for interpretation in the taste
of the smoothie that is
somehow an artistic message
somehow to achieve with it i
recently the team gave me
he told himself about dad it was just as easy
it was a long story the smell is already
penetrating also this
year is also
celebrating
that i didn't hear that i
'm going to check it out he was three weeks
ago it was just legendary the guy is
cool is also charged with energy and also
around them too in global creator but from
germany something like that should
be really cool i celebrate that's
why i drive it a lot and there are
no cool topics in germany you
don't have to hide it under a bushel
even though it's germany  always so
i mean you yourself now with grandma and
also with the with the with the happening
with your even  ts shows that yes you can
do great [ __ ] there are good start
ups good good ideas there are good creator
inventory there is everything and you
don't always have to like america and always
somehow everything is better there and that's how
it is so often i don't know either  so what
's mostly wrong but
it means there won't be a netflix
documentary about you soon
maybe yes they should be offered
at the table
and but nft as I mean
the auo and fishy topic
so there's no
fcn so look  I think the technology behind it is
fabulous and I think it's
really awesome and I think it's
relevant I just said before that I
believe in such a democratization of
content and I believe that more and
more of this content creator to the
user I believe  at some point this
distribution platform will disappear because i
think it will just be a better
experience for the users and
the experience will be better curated i think  e
at some point people will also say
I no longer feel like consuming according to the
algorithm but I want to consume
intrinsically myself again
, you see, you
can do that with many apps too,
instagram has now brought it back on
reddit, you can do that well  you
just hate your feed the way it is
just still so right in time stop and
come on we have to yes i dont have
either yes i am enjoying the time
and i think a fts can play a
big role as for everyone so in the
song could be lft
however that is then somehow
reflected but i think this
city use case is not that
bad customer is really bad
it is bad so just
get rid of all those weird jetpacks which
in the end mostly just me there is
money laundering and and and and so on  many exit
scams without end dude, I mean
it can hardly be counted on one hand how
many big scams there really were in
two  listen to hundreds of millions and even
more and that's just [ __ ] for me
this i'm doing now
somehow one way or another [ __ ] as
crass overrated [ __ ] it's
clear that people have it back on their
apple watch and then they have it
over their board apes, so to speak  as
harry somehow 100 million chf inheritance and
that somehow makes a percentage of a
portfolio you say ok i
want somehow because this market is new
and then you invest wildly in there
or take the most established one
wooden ladder then thing from that is
legitimate  but if you're like you
say you're jealous then all the more birds whose
90 percent of your portfolio
is this one nfc and then it's okay then
you're the side part I'll say for
myself that you're legally half the
citizen in the room
what we are  that's maybe a bit too
important i mean what now
let's say let's continue to experience in my childhood
how difficult it is
economic success  e how
problematic it is if you don't
just
do that have you thought again
about how do I invest my money
so we don't keep here what
you actually do so well well I first learned at some
point so
first I have one  separation made
and what is real prosperity and what
is perceived prosperity so
prosperity and financial freedom are
also topics that you have to separate somehow
because everyone defines prosperity
differently so for someone my
life is the absolute dream life and i
know many creators and and  artists who have
just as much,
not many, but a few who have just as much
money as me and who are totally
unhappy, they just
always strive for people who have a lot
more and say or only then am
I happy, that means that
I have it  I said goodbye quickly
so okay what is my reality and what
are the things where I say that is
where for me  hlstand and that’s what i have in
corona so that’s for example so
i can say for example that’s
also a part of prosperity for me i
can say that krone was positive for
me even though i suffered blatant financial
damage as a result but that
doesn’t matter to me  plays because i had
my finances under control
and he was
able to turn that into a positive experience, for example,
just discovering a lot of things
i was allowed to watch a concert even i myself, as a
rule, which was prosperous for me
what is what in things
i don’t care about  want to do without in my
job and i
quickly noticed, for example, that these are usually
not topics that are associated with so much
money what i love, for example,
is simple i can get up as
i want and i can also organize my work
as i want  well i mean of
course i also have a number of
appointments and i also have an apple
diary but and i also have
a to-  to-do list every day and sometimes
i get it sometimes i do
n't get it but i can still push it
if i say now an
old friend is calling me yes and i can i
just say this
interpersonal interaction is
more important to me now i just can  say i
don't have to call a boss i do
n't have to call anyone i can just
say what i'm doing i'll postpone this to-do list
to next week i
'm going to eat now and won't say i'll
benefit from this great
interpersonal experience and
what i do  luxury
reference to a regular partner
here in the podcast, all sorts of
things. ko aleikum is a young
company that tries to
close the gap between what e-commerce
shops and retailers can currently do
and what buyers
often expect  have the right
feeling for the customer proactive shipping
communication track and trace a
digital at the tour portal all
customers simply expect that many companies
can't afford it like that then
aleikum does it all, they make
sure that you make your fulfillment as a
retailer much easier if
you survive it and you can
escalate infinitely there is a very
simple control of the aleikum platform
colleague paul ripke told a few
weeks ago in the podcast about rajko
he also uses it for his grand paris
just like many others die tussi
film including chocolate no
wonder that at mr reviews the
rating of rajko users is well above the
industry average, i.e. the stars
which are obviously distributed
much higher if you want to know
more about all the information on the landing page
reiko dot com
mr
you want to say that you now for your
the lifestyle you want to have in the next few years
until you retire or until you
die not there until now  through so there
is now taken care of at the end that
could already do it without  e that
you ever do anything again we
're springtime so my
husband paid off my house
my costs are pretty much minimized
so I was an electric car I even have
photovoltaics on my roof and
throw that in so I ca
n't run it 100 percent of it  but
partly
that means i'm also quite
productive my studio area is also
very small so my well
my
business
expenses i could for the next five years with a concert hall
[laughter]
current setup like that and i play
like that no idea 20 years from a year
so
without a tour now just talking about
[laughter]
fender i was able to see
through everything with kroner masses
and i could, for example, treat myself to
this luxury and say i'm making
a progressive album i don't have
to pay attention to it like the quartet i do
n't have to  pay attention to how it streams and
for example is also this luxury to
say i had to do social media
and i didn't have to do it the
way i don't like it so i don't have to i don't have to do it
i have i don't have to
do things financially
driven i can see things much much more
rationally i
deal with things a lot of time i can live  I can also take
more time for myself. I can
do things I would say intrinsically. I
can say I'm doing it because
I want to or because I have to and I can do a
lot of things because I want them
and I have to do a few things
and that's it  a huge luxury for me
but still be careful it will probably
start again
so
I have no idea I think I have
something in the double digits
I think at some point between 10 and
20 festivals I didn’t
look in the folder and you do
n’t come around at
11:23 p.m. that means  one of
the shows can i would say that's great for
us are you then with us in hamburg is
the first show was okay
so ask how  is what usually comes with
a tour ticket from you
just i was
already on your come and
our fair ticket also costs 49 euros
that means you get somehow you eat
you are that's a lot more
what we here in somehow for for
everyone affordable in hamburg and
but ok maybe not
get in that will probably be
difficult enough but i am looking forward to
it he will she still play so
which festivals mostly already so this
yes this headline i think i think all
major festivals in the roof so why
no rain  and should all of this
be advised to yourselves his game or
roasted summer yes of course there
is that too so that
we always make two year plans in advance
so we meet my lawyer and
my mother once a year and
then everything will be fine  everything is calculated as
is pre-calculated, that means before i
even go on stage i know
what i will earn that day  for
example, many
artists don't do it like that and even I have
n't done it for a while and
countries also fell in the face with
order of magnitude is already way more constant
seven digits at the end of the so
definitely I have mine now per evening so
six per evening  yes quite lucrative
business yes yes but of course as I said it
's great and you were at the concert
I was at so it really must be
a very very good memory for me before krone
that was I think I did it again in
2009/10 sports hall yes there was
I mean hamburg I also have a brutal
fan base so I can it is confirmed I
was totally flabbergasted what I wasn't so clear to myself
is you have
a bit of that this time too so I asked that
I stand by well a bit  on the
edge and once it's really going
on who should moshpit earlier somehow
it's a bit like that as a teenager
style how it's going to happen that that
's not just for me  r well i established it
in germany i would say
and made it big but that
has meanwhile i would say part of hip
hop won rage this punk is
definitely i think already completely
established in every modern hip hop show
maybe maybe last
year was just probable  you have exactly
i don't think you have a lot of
other early hip hop i was there
so that
okay his last topic like podcast
i know that you think about it from time to
time i also
tried to lure you into knowing or how
fuxtest yes so  I'm
back to the topic from before, so I
had to I
just don't have to hurry I have to
do it, then if it suits me, I can
do it according to the frequency that
suits me and I can also structure it in terms of
content  how that suits me because
it didn't have to make money but if
i do it then i do it because it
gives me fulfillment
and i'm with  you can
say to me i'm planning with myself as well as
when and
how you can easily implement it so
that we too i'm
ultimately always concerned with the
product i'm doctor peil that
means now clothes be it a
promo phase  it's now in summer it's
a podcast or something like that it's always
about the product it's always about me being
free in this whole wind that will
probably get bigger and bigger over the years
as far as facets are concerned
that simply always qualitative
products come in there too  the good frequency
without that somehow i don't like things like
that you always notice that especially in the urban area
or i
think in the entrepreneurial area
things are somehow started quickly
because somewhere there is
this thing again people can only
read numbers people have
I no longer have my own understanding of art. Things
just start because you notice
something twitches somewhere
and ok and then they do it  ute
and then that's the way it is and you
probably will because you also
do podcasts for others and you'll
notice that very quickly and
then it probably won't
be able to sing about it either, if at some point
something doesn't work out then the motivation
is there  straight away because there was no other
motivation apart from somehow but that
has to make a reach or that has to
make money like that and if that's always
the key motivator I can
say for most of us it doesn't matter that applies
to everyone then most of them will
projects simply fail
and aren't fun either and you
won't get very far with the
things you do either. That's why I was particularly
interested in the podcast when I
heard that the subject was when we
exchanged ideas and finally
somehow noticed it
because I think
you have such a very committed
community around you, that's
the way it works, people  you're really that hardcore
i would have my partner is
think it works he told me
how intensively he answers everyone every day
the ems writes back without
end then day somehow i know
300 dm answer it you do
it that way so the place is  because he is
really good that you have the complete social
media ag he really cracked all the
algorithms and as you can
see in the last few years he has performed really well
so he definitely has one of the best
understanding of social media and
i have known that for a long time  so
knowing the internet was the most powerful thing
on my second tour so i
know i know before
bryant i know his first attempts
who his first police and everything
so i'm pretty into it i have
too i was sort of the first too
consumer of
after the other
first generation biggest hip hop
bands in germany it's better that's more or
less i was also the first
ku  nde and the first one i would say
range giver so that he is also
working with us now for example
hannover he is our
managing director and
soest as well as small circle is a
bit bitter but i speak german
sometimes we were talking during the
day because the cooperation
is  that's good and that also fits very well
into his thing but i'm we're
not that big corp
against a little bit so i
knew the added value for us well well i don't
see it right now
maybe cross normal bayern none
idea i think i think help
recognize each other also i don't know
do you do brand collaborations in
general so i get rid of myself so we
'll do a lot for so long yes
this year i wo
n't reveal anything about it of course but there will
be a lot of them so there will be  there
will
be huge, important things that
have never been done here in
germany, but not with big
brands where  the wind you so brand the
best of the testimonials for because not
good stand
up and protectors these big
fashion companies series all meanwhile
uncool
[music]
we won't create any products
it's not about me being the
main model somewhere or then somehow that
's even  at this rummaging that's
so this half there was
maybe you know the cani it works
that was back then when lady about this
creative director hype there was already
in the late nineties
with this where he says yes is lady gaga
now creative director at polaroid where
he says alexander gaga's song spot
factor china about cameras so and that's the way it
is that's why it's like
this this eternal messing about with each other he had
an unnecessary collaboration where no
thread leads to each other where you
just notice ok old brand old  large
established brand wants to do something with
something young no one on the
board has planners there happened no one
has a plan what they are doing there ov  in general
these young people do brake or these guys
creator it's just
about okay they have cool social media
numbers they're kinda young
kinda
let's do something like that they're
allowed to redesign any of
our products and then you've got
this cheese  but if there were more interest
bands now or
maybach that's complete crap from
virgil so what's eating important guy and he
's also done great things but
that's one of the main things college
that's right this old company
something young so ok often  did a couple of
cool things what the heck they came
to do with expressive
so where is the added value now apart from
creating some car with
the hostess a colored switched or something
or because that’s my but i think there
are designers like that so i’m  I
care a lot about kuka is good now you do
n't even know about the happy feet is one of
the first with beetle that started like
that d  This clearly has culture but I think
it brings something in so if
he made a lot of cheese
because a lot of cool collapse but made a lot of
scrap so thirsty so the end
also made a lot of things for the first time
in this ship universe of course
did a lot of things and especially in
this sneaker space he did a lot of
cool things but also a lot of
scrap ok and
porsche for example a lot of coal
college wasn't made with k so with
the automobil that's for example one of
the biggest and most important car collectors
in the world so
powerful the the coolest car collection that's a
real one who also has a clue and he
was then allowed to design porsche, for example,
and you'll immediately notice the difference
from anyone who knows the brand, you'll notice
what a college can look like when
which works on mutual appreciation
and also on an equal footing, which
means that both parties have an idea of
oduct and both  part
know how they work together
so and then there can be really cool
things didn't have your drobner all the
time these porsche things and so
and not somehow over half so
that was a little cool thing there was
also a beautiful
car because of that  type idea of cars has l
ke this and then it just goes together like this
ut this i think it will also turn out l
ke this toth kolab i mean you see now f
r example herin
and lvmh then at so
e point we collaborated on all these young creat
r deaths  and also
bought death and the tip will
be that they just keep making bracket apps with each other that
already exists
within the big corporations so at
lvmh you then have this whole cheese Remo
it was all sorts of things  those who
otherwise have in the group will then
somehow be crossed
again through just crossed ones and now they
will be  t still do mutually with
others and then this crisis
will hopefully be finally over and
all this defiant value is commercial
collapse hear simply also because
it's just rip-off that's means
you don't see any cola from you there
you get if cool college comes along
a history and with someone on an
equal footing even with big brands
but it will be conclusive and you
will market so that you work with
each other with respect and you
try to create a cool break
and you don't just
say hey let's have our two
sticking the main logos together and products that
he already has up his sleeve just put down
such great numbers around labels in a different color
and that’s
a great college and yes i
wasn’t katja with the actually
know all the blogs or
textmaker and stuff like that  and the name of the readers
means as soon as the readers and means
that the bosses and I
always said in the e  As a result, you also have to be
careful not to always step into these numbers
so that you
just burned away somehow featured that
only have big numbers and because that
will also cause many blogs and chats
to complain because I see in
the last few years
how they then all
collapse in the ranges and even the
big brakes lose their own
protective mechanisms and then say yes,
how then collaborate with them
because we notice or kuhl the am so
many followers on install and I find
that a way and there  I'll always be
that the work is and there's
no collaboration that's somehow really
finished,
it's no longer clear in
which area you'll work in the documentation, where they
come from, so that he might care about
it, it's also things that are
completely obvious  lie it's
just about the way
work is done and also internally
the goods are on an equal footing that you really work
I'm collaborating and the
things people now apart from it have
never been able to understand, they
don't understand at all how bad this whole
collapse is that hardly anyone
talks to each other
in any way, they're kind of agencies and
then they're graphic agencies, they clap the
two logos together  on 400 pages and
then there is a storm of e-mails from
some weird marketing
director and such and no one for them it
's all just a topic yes and as soon as it's
over it's just
a spot topic for them it's for the nasa
folder  that just has to be worked through
now so no art can do it alone
and that's the truth you'll
probably know that too that's
just a wide-ranging topic a cool
that's a target group we do
n't have because we collaborate with them
that means little will happen  worked
with i really celebrate what they do
or they really celebrate what we do
or understand what  we make
most of the collapses that i've brought to
it is because people have talked to
me and have noticed
orchestra really deals with the
material and have noticed orchestra
who really have passion and plan for
the thing and
that's why they always want it to happen
again  we don't even work together
for the biggest i mean we have
just over 30 thousand followers with lukas
and videos you've noticed yourself i
don't have the biggest channel as a
hip hopper either but people want to
work with me because they know that we
deliver quality  that we only work with people
who know what we
're doing and that we work on things with knowledge and passion and that's
why they want to work with us that's
why people also want to work with
elvira not because he focuses on
every topic because it somehow has it
but because he himself
rules but because he focuses on topics
that are good for the skin and i  Somehow also
move something and I think we are all the
same ok so I am very happy for
listeners to this podcast who so far
there have also been different
target groups to hear so far have not
heard any of your
songs which means recommend what
you hear her first
i don't know i have too many
facets but what is the intro song to
2 there is must hear everything i have a
very very big i have a very big world
there is something for many people
i don't have any in the meantime  ahnung everything
done from indie rock to grunge to classic hip-hop
to nine what was
the corn guy is also in the tube
the east the most tuned he's
okay there was whoever wants to hear like this
guy here will be the most popular song
and exactly one  mainstream people
are supposed to just listen to your ears
, if so, if you
haven't experienced nato as an artist,
then do it, then know  is what you
can hopefully look forward to if the game is somehow
a few weeks in hamburg and you listen to
the german free games podcast promised me
you
think of the deer sinking when it comes
that's even that told
and then we'll see a few  weeks
in hamburg, by the way, also explained for you
guest very very cool
so we saved with that means correspond to that
everyone is on the road sometimes so let me
know if
you want to look at something special internally or want to meet him
away from your appearance
I'll see if I'm there  a
bit if there are a few people
that i somehow so maybe
i can call david myself
is okay that would be something like that in the
afternoon who i would like
to spend two minutes with the nonsense
and first know the awe
that he works then
you have something  the content is the
take away motto don't like
to go there i'm a fanboy again
renate on many  thank you for your time
and for the honest everyday life
thank you thank you a
little reference to what remained in germany
is the software for customer messaging
the company is called user like and enables
both live chat via the website in
real time with the respective visitors
of the company website and also mobile
messaging i.e. direct exchange
between a company and its
customers via voip or streamer or sms
for systems that are currently very
relevant for marketing, companies often need
a platform that enables everything from a single source
, which then also
ensures that the respective inbound
messages from the customers go directly to the
right people  the
company ensures
that the topic of data protection is handled according to
German standards, the
automation and chats enable all
that does user like from mercedes-benz has an
idea and we rely on this like who
is wanting to rest the topic of messaging
and live chat right now  look  t measure is
but according to this live.com / mr for
our listeners there are also the first
words a little cheaper me 30 percent
cheaper with the voucher code
written in lower case he underlined 2022
this podcast is produced by
popstars
at mr